we've seen these these Office Parks with
lots of buildings and they get pretty
boring Pretty Fast so we'd like to do
something Better Than that we've come up
with design that puts 12,000 people in
one building that was late Apple
co-  founder Steve Jobs in 2011 making his
last Public appearance at a Cupertino
City council hearing for apples proposed
New Corporate Campus a few weeks ago The
Doors of Jobs Dream Corporate
headquarters open
some employees This is Run Of The Off
building some the mass Complex looks
like a  Giant spaceship just landed in
Silicon Valley back Channel editor and
Chief Steven Levy got an Exclusive
invite to Tour apples glit New digs and
writ about it in this month's issue of
wired Magazine ST good morning good
morning Steve Jobs Called It The Best
Office building in the
world spectacular building I think to
tell the best Office building in
the it is designed for the Max and people
in Special but I think it's going to
take quite a while and see how people
work in it before you figure
out people I mean 12000 that's Inc  am of
people that's a lot of people Apple was
spread out all over certin which is
headquarter city Steve Jobs hometown And
they're very excited to bring the people
Together they're All To Run each
the CCF
mass tells US about your Experience when
you  walk through the doors for the first
time right when you first encounter the
building it really is massive you know
we went in a Jeep into the
construction S they were Just completing
the construction in March when i visited
a few times and uh you go through  this
Tunnel look like What the Holland or
Lincoln Tunnel must look like when it
was New it's gleaming and Beautiful and
then you Circle the building there's a
road around it and It's almost like
orbiting a
Planet you go around because it has
these giant Glass walls these  panels
that are curved and you Circle around it
but interestingly when you're inside the
building you don't get that overwhelming
feeling of scale It's actually more
serene probably Because The Glass walls
are on either side It's Never Too Wide
at Any Point it's a  ring and you really
feel what's going on outside you get the
light and the building really so you get
a sense of What It's like outside sort
of partly in Nature so How involved was
Jobs actually in the design he was
really deeply involved it and It's
Amazing  that this is the last Two Years
Of His Life he spent a considerable
amount of Time planning this things the
architects told me they would Go For All
day meetings with him and they were
afraid to leave to go to the bathroom
because you know he would  just come
up more details and more things exactly
The way heed it the innovations don't
end with the walls innovations
I some that Apple even designed New pza
Box for some of employees here What's
that all about that's right Everything
door handles sprinklers fonts on the
elevators in this Case you know the
fellow that Steve Jobs hired to run the
cafes there we H from his favorite
Restaurant uh patented a Pizza Box he
invented a Pizza Box which is actually
quite Clever yeah It's round It's got
holes got little thing Bottom the CR
doesn't you know pza actually It's
pretty good What are What are some Of
The Perks that the 12000 employees can
expect in this place well there's
probably most spectacular Fitness and
Wellness Center youve ever seen it makes
The equinox Look like Rocky
Gym you know they  've Got You a two Story
yoga room with Stone imported From This
qu in Kansas I mean that brings up a
Point that other people on the outside
of me which is isn't this
bive Apple's View Is that if they
Wills go to the CBS  cafeteria and check
out our triangular cardboard
pizza boxes to see maybe lic
apples Thanks for your time